Let's go.
Oh,
Charles rocks.
Wasn't that good the other day.
Charles Keith,
you liked that lecture?
He's very,
he's excellent.
He did a seminar on an imperialism,
uh,
last year,
which is very good.
Before I start,
I just wanted to,
uh,
just,
just to give you,
uh,
you know,
a visual idea of,
um,
of the new imperialism that is the
period he was talking about from the mid
1880s,
let's say 1884,
1885 to 1914.
So what to focus on is just when you're
looking at this thing is there's Africa.
Okay.
There's Africa.
So you've got a few little,
you know,
a few little splotches.
And they weren't even,
they weren't even maps so much
of the internal part of Africa.
So that,
that's 1880.
And I'll look at this.
That's 1914.
So something has happened in between,
which is that the scramble for colonies
has literally eaten up the entire
continent.
Uh,
and the places that,
that,
uh,
you know,
th the Charles were talking
about was obviously west Africa,
basically here,
west Africa and now Mali and Senegal.
And,
and you know,
Algeria,
obviously Morocco and,
and,
uh,
um,
you know,
Indonesia and,
and that sort of thing.
And then the rest you just see,
uh,
but that,
that,
but it's an extraordinary,
extraordinary,
uh,
um,
contrast in there.
And there's flush Shota which
is where the [inaudible] the,
the two,
a Expeditionary Force stumble
into each other and there,
and there was a thought of,
of,
of war and,
uh,
they settled it there with a few drinks,
but then,
uh,
that the,
foreign ministers go wild.
And it's a,
it's all that.
Uh,
so just to remind you of the context.
So that's what I'm going
to talk about today.
I don't know if are you recording yet,
but,
uh,
we can.
Yup.
Okay.
Um,
so just to put this in context of,
you know,
the diplomatic origins of,
uh,
of world war one,
because I mean,
the traditional image of
all this isn't a bad one.
It's the entangling alliances,
uh,
that create this kind of house of cards,
that when a war Br,
if first breaks out a or for that
matter when the Russian empire declares
mobilization of its armies,
uh,
that the house of cards will collapse.
And,
uh,
the great powers minus,
Italy,
which we'll wait for the
highest bidder in 1915,
uh,
go to war.
So how did this,
I mean,
how,
how does this all happen
briefly in 45 minutes?
How does this happen?
Um,
first of all,
I mean the old and,
and,
and towards the end of the,
of the hour,
I'll have towards the
end of the 45 minutes,
I'll talk a little bit about one specific,
uh,
affair that kind of demonstrates the,
the intensity of what,
what had happened.
Uh,
and,
and the shift of from away from England
being perceived as is arguably Francis
greatest enemy despite SSRN to that of
Germany and the dissolver and affairs is
Ivonne,
a s a,
v,
e,
r,
n,
e or in German,
Zabil on a,Z ,
but,
but of course,
lots of,
lots of the diplomatic,
you know,
history of,
of this period.
Um,
uh,
and at first revolves around the
MTT between France and Germany.
And specifically as you've
heard over and over again,
uh,
Alsace a law man.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
one can debate,
uh,
as historians have to what extent revenge,
permeated,
uh,
the ranks of French society,
thoughts of taking back Ssrn,
uh,
through the whole period.
And as I said a few minutes ago,
if you'd ask people in 1890s,
who France would go to war against,
uh,
you know,
if they had poles in those days,
most people would've said Britain
more about that in a while.
Uh,
but it was always there.
It was always there for Otto von Bismarck,
uh,
as he's trying to assure that,
that,
uh,
if Germany does go to war,
it won't have to fight
his worst nightmare.
That is a war on two fronts.
And that's exactly what happens
when the French and the Russians,
uh,
a get together.
Um,
and so I mean that,
that's the,
that's a major issue in,
in western Europe is obviously
the relationship between
these folks and El Sauce
and the parts of Lauryn,
uh,
that had been a next into,
the German empire.
And next rather,
and comfortably as we'll see a in a while
and the other may I just have to dodge
these peripherally.
Uh,
but,
but it's important to
at least you and you,
I'm sure you know about them anyway.
But,
uh,
you know,
the other thing that is
going to hinge on is the,
uh,
really the hatred between Russia and,
and Austria,
Hungary.
Um,
and,
and the fact that,
that the Russians see themselves
as the protector of the,
of the Slavic peoples,
uh,
in,
in the Balkans.
And the fact that the Austrian
Hungarian empire is a polyglot empire.
That is,
you've got at least,
depending on how you count them,
15 major nationalities when the empire,
uh,
and that,
although,
uh,
Germany,
German is the language of,
of the Empire that Austria,
Hungary,
uh,
these ethnic minorities and their
claims for national independence,
uh,
exists as a,
as a perpetual destabilizing factor
in Austrian Hungarian politics,
particularly when Russia,
which is always dreamt of Constantinople
and controlling the access to the Black
Sea is fanning the flames of,
of nationalism,
of Slavic,
uh,
of Pan Slava Islam,
but also of nationalism
within these various states,
which destabilizes,
uh,
potentially the Austro-hungarian Empire
and the Austrian Hungarian Empire became
the dual monarchy before
this course starts.
But in 18,
I,
67,
it's run out of Vienna,
which is that city which has left by
the treaty of Versailles and the other
treaties,
uh,
after war one is this enormous,
the capital,
uh,
of a tiny country when the
empire empire disappears.
A,
but that is,
uh,
rushing a,
of the story,
you know,
a rushing to,
to the end of the story,
but by a 1900,
uh,
Russia is,
is a fanning the flames of pen,
a Slav,
a fervor,
uh,
in,
um,
the,
the mountain is a territories
of Bosnia Herzegovina,
uh,
which include is,
you know,
from the tragedies of,
of the,
you know,
the,
the ethnic cleansing of the 1990 serves,
uh,
Muslims and,
and Catholic,
uh,
Croats.
Now the alliance system
of the late 19th century,
which in its own way help,
uh,
is one of the causes of World War One.
There are others too that
I'll discuss in a while.
Uh,
but it hinges on German and
French antagonism and it,
and it hinges on the competing
interests of Austria,
Hungary,
and Russia in the Balkans.
And I hear,
I'm summarizing a Germany's fear of
being attacked from both east and west by
Russia and France.
So at the beginning you've got,
those are three,
there are five big powers.
And,
and at Bismarck once said,
you know,
and it uses a French phrase,
which is interesting because France,
France was always the
language of diplomacy,
says the most important thing
is to be Artois to be three.
If they're five,
you want to be three.
But,
uh,
what you have basically is
to potential free agents.
Um,
a free agent,
uh,
with a big appetite,
been very bad teeth as some wag ones,
put it Italy here,
uh,
which would go to the highest bidder,
1915 and Great Britain.
Now Great Britain.
It's not a natural given that
Great Britain was going to,
you know,
ally with France,
it's great enemy for centuries,
uh,
or ally with Russia because Britain and
Russia have been fighting for very long
time.
What some,
another wag one's called the,
you know,
the great game,
which is for control a long place.
It's,
we hear much about these days,
uh,
such as northern India,
Pakistan,
you know,
all the way along into South Asia.
So,
you know,
they are rivals,
uh,
for,
you know,
for influence in all sorts
of different parts of,
of this huge mass of,
of,
of Asia,
uh,
in the largest sense of the world.
So word.
So it's a,
one of the thing,
you know,
you have to ask if you're just thinking
about it from a point of Frances,
how does it happen that in 1914,
that,
uh,
France finds itself,
allied with Great Britain
and with Great Britain,
sometimes enemy,
uh,
that is Russia.
And also from the point of view,
if you were a French republican
or you're a French socialist,
who is a believer in the Republican,
most of them,
most of them were,
uh,
how do you explain how a republican
state is allied with the czar,
uh,
czarist regime and autocracy a
repressor of all of the peoples and,
uh,
among other things,
orchestrator,
uh,
encourage your facilitator
enabler of a vicious pogrom,
a pogroms against,
uh,
against the Jews.
So how this happens,
you know,
is it,
it's extremely interesting
and it means that,
you know,
these powers are on the
search for allies who are,
um,
going to,
uh,
give them,
you know,
uh,
give them an advantage.
Should Europe go to war?
Now later on,
uh,
I will make the case,
and it's the obvious one to make is that,
that most people who followed such
wing things expected a war in their
lifetimes.
There had not been a major,
Major Kline for conference
[inaudible] for,
so Gracian since ninth,
10th,
Waterloo,
basically,
you'd had wars.
Uh,
you have,
you know,
fighting after the 1848 revolutions,
the intervention of the Russian army,
you have the Crimean war,
often Crimea,
appropriately enough,
1853,
1856,
you have Russia.
I mean,
but Prussia fighting Austria in 1866,
you have the Franco Prussian war,
as you know,
in 1870,
71.
But basically this period is
sometimes referred to in textbooks.
I don't know if in mind it is or not,
but it's the,
it's the Pax Britannica,
uh,
because,
you know,
England rules the waves,
et cetera,
et cetera.
But most people thought
there would be a war,
uh,
in their lifetime because of these
antagonisms more than that many people,
how many,
it's difficult to say wanted
a war more about that later.
They expected a war,
but nobody expected award that
would carry away four empires,
uh,
and millions of lives and will
last way over four years and would,
as I've said before,
unleash the demons of the 20th century.
So in 1879,
Bismarck for just the
cornerstone alliance,
um,
between Germany and Austria,
Hungary,
and it's predicated on German,
um,
uh,
support for Austria,
Hungary and resistant Hungarian resistance
against Russia's activities in the
Balkans.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so that,
that,
that is a key alliance.
And one of the continuity's of this
entire period from 1879 to 1914 is this
alliance,
which will become more formalized later.
And this explains why it was in July of
1914 the Germans give the famous blank
check and that's a good way of putting it.
A blank check to Austria,
Hungary after the assassination of the
archduke Franz Ferdinand and Sarah Navel
on the 28th of June,
1914 and they say,
you can do whatever you want to Serbia
and we will back you all the way and back
you all.
The way is,
is,
that's a big statement because that
means we will back you even in involves
eventually going to war with these guys.
You know,
with uh,
the Russian army,
the Russian masses,
the Russian nationalities,
and nobody really knew.
I mean,
the Russian army had been
defeated and navy as well.
It had been humiliated by the Japanese
in the Russian Japanese war of 1904 1905.
So nobody really knows what,
you know what this is going to be like,
but they all know it's going to take
two weeks for Russia to mobilize its
armies.
How do you get all these
people from here to there,
yet one railroad line running,
which would cost them in 1904,
1905 running the Vladivostok the port,
you know,
on the,
on the Pacific Ocean or,
well,
I don't know if it's on the
yellow Sierra Pacific Ocean,
but it's,
you know,
way,
way far away.
I've never been to Vladivostok.
Um,
but anyway,
this is the key,
uh,
you know,
the first chip or the first part or
the first block of this alliance and,
and it's,
it's 1879 now a year later,
Italy ally's itself also with,
with Austria,
Hungary,
and,
um,
with,
with Germany.
Um,
but there are all sorts of,
of,
of what if,
what if,
but if,
uh,
you know,
attached to that alliance
in Italy basically is,
is a,
um,
a free,
a free lance,
uh,
a loose cannon,
during,
uh,
the entire,
the entire period.
Now,
um,
the last thing that Bismarck once
remember Bismark's out of there,
you may not know this,
but he's out of there in about 1894.
Isn't that a,
he dies I think in 1894,
if I remember right.
So He's,
he's not around but,
but his nightmare is
Germany being encircled.
And the last thing that he wanted to
see happen in his lifetime or in the
lifetimes of his,
uh,
somewhat hapless successors,
you know,
with the very end that did the demand
with the so much of a authority over or a
foreign policy is this is this lagoon
bruhs sad man called Beckman Holdaway
whose name you can,
you can forget who was convinced he
wants tell us his son don't plan a lot of
trees on our,
on our estates because the
Russians eventually will
come and take these estates
and they won't do any good.
And he had this sort of fatalism that,
that uh,
uh,
he was convinced,
that there will have to be a war.
And he went and says that necessity,
a chilling phrase that that
is echoed in our own time,
in need in our own country.
Sometimes necessity knows no law.
Uh,
uh,
but anyway,
all of the successors of Bismarck with
the last thing they want to do with is to
see,
uh,
France ally with these guys here.
Now,
how does that happen?
I mean the,
uh,
if you,
if you go to Paris and you go to the,
uh,
one of the more beautiful bridges of
Paris from the end of the 19th century is
the Po Alexon Twat the bridge
of Alexander the third,
which is sort of beautiful
at his art nouveau touches.
And,
and here with this odd scene of the
czar repressor of all of the peoples,
uh,
you know,
showing up and they having to teach the,
the,
the French marine band how to
play the theme song of the czar,
whatever that is.
Uh,
and the Russian military ban
learning there must say yes.
How,
how in Congress,
since the last thing
that the Russians are,
would ever contemplate was the
kind of government that France has.
How does that happen?
That is really extraordinary.
Well,
it has to do with,
uh,
you know,
with fear of Germany.
But there are other things that,
that I should mention just briefly that,
that drive these too
improbable powers together.
Um,
and,
uh,
besides the cultural factor because,
you know,
lots of people,
lots of the Russian elite,
uh,
some spoke German depending on where
they live and Koenigsberg and places like
that.
They spoke German,
but,
um,
lots of,
of,
of of them spoke French.
And you had these sort of cultural ties.
My mother,
uh,
who grew up in Battle Creek,
Michigan of all places,
Kellogg's of Battle Creek,
she was taught French.
They're not very well by a Russian,
um,
a member of the Russian royal family,
you know,
who are the,
all these people when they,
and they have to go after,
after the Russian of the
Bolshevik revolution,
you know,
they come to the United
States and lots of them.
I have a student working on this now and
being taxi drivers in Paris and some of
them come to the United States and,
and uh,
and,
and the more he well heeled ones,
some of them getting jobs,
teaching,
uh,
French.
But that enough,
it's the old cultural connection is,
you know,
isn't all that important and that's not
going to drive them together at all.
But there are other forces besides,
uh,
you know,
after 1879,
a potential common enemy,
particular this one a,
and one of them is economic investment
is that one of those things I mentioned
before about French investors is that,
uh,
those with capital to invest
are frequently investing
outside of France and they
invest heavily in Russia.
There is still some suits
somewhere in which some,
a French company is trying to get from,
from the Russia of,
of Putin.
Uh,
money bat lost in 1917.
It is still going on.
And so lots of money was invested in um,
uh,
in Russia,
particularly in Russian railroads.
They invest in,
in Spanish railroads and an Italian
railroads and in other things as well.
But there is,
this is this conduit and money,
you know,
money has a big influence
in diplomatic matters.
And if you're trying to explain why it,
why it is that,
uh,
the French ambassador forget,
totally forgettable guy
called the [inaudible] pain.
Paleo log is chasing around in the garden,
representatives of the,
of the czar,
uh,
trying to firm up the,
the,
uh,
the details that,
that,
that Russia will,
if Francis invaded by Germany,
uh,
you know,
move its armies in this
direction and an attack Russia,
you have to go back to,
um,
uh,
to that,
that fundamental fact is that,
uh,
these economic ties helps solidify,
the sort of great power,
uh,
arrangements,
that are being,
that there are being,
um,
uh,
a made.
And so in 1889,
the year of the centenary of the French
Revolution here is the czar of Russia,
uh,
showing up in Paris and,
and being welcomed enthusiastically.
Uh,
and,
uh,
of course,
the Socialists don't like it at all.
Uh,
because of,
uh,
you know,
a,
and this wasn't even,
this was before the pogrom in,
in,
in 1905,
uh,
in,
in particularly in Crimea,
but in other places,
uh,
as well.
Um,
and so in 1892,
France and Russia sign a military,
a treaty,
uh,
by which each pledge of military response
if the other were attacked by Germany
or by one or more of its allies.
And there's a formal alliance in 1894.
Now,
formal alliances are not published
in figure out Ho or in Utah,
in newspapers,
but everybody knows the
rough outlines of this.
Everybody knows,
nobody has any illusions in London,
uh,
in Vienna,
in Berlin,
about what,
you know,
what this,
this,
uh,
a treaty,
a means.
And what this does is it ends what
Bismarck had intended the economic,
I mean that,
that diplomatic isolation of France.
Um,
and now these guys are,
are surrounded.
Now how does Britain
get into this briefly?
Well,
Britain gets into this,
um,
in the following way,
uh,
that,
Germany basically becomes a much
bigger economic rival than anyone else,
uh,
that the German economy,
particularly industrial
economy grows rapidly.
Uh,
uh,
they,
virtually they're nipping at the British
heels in terms of steel production.
They're cranking out huge battleships,
which are called dreadnought.
Battleships are the,
that's just the size of the ship.
I,
and has an advantage in
military things to be,
have the latest guns and the latest
ships as opposed to ones made older,
uh,
and that sort of thing.
So there are nipping at their
heels and then some aspects,
even steel production increasing and they,
they,
they go way ahead in chemistry.
The Germans are without any question,
you know,
the leading power,
uh,
in chemical production account,
chemical expert experimentation,
and the universities play a major,
major role in that.
Um,
so,
uh,
and that,
with his economic rivalry,
uh,
is,
which has,
you know,
has things evolved in Africa,
uh,
you know,
imperial rivalry there,
et Cetera,
uh,
goes the naval rivalry that heats up,
after the of the century.
Uh,
and,
uh,
in both Germany and in,
in,
in Britain as in France,
you've got these navy,
Naval Leagues,
you've got these groups of citizens,
you know,
invite admirals to dinner to give
thundering speeches about defeating,
you know,
the perfidious Albion are
defeating and I'm whomever,
you know,
they all,
they want.
But what they really want to do is to get,
to get their countries to build more,
uh,
more big ships.
And of course,
industrialists just love that.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the,
the stuff that Charles was
talking about the other day,
I mean,
you bring,
you know,
bring a,
and explored a lunch and have
him talk about how awful the,
you know,
the horrible huns are.
That is the Germans,
the bullsh and all that effort
in the French case and it all.
And so they have this big,
big rivalry going on because Britain's
control of the C's is basically,
uh,
Ben.
For centuries in world war one,
there was only one naval
battle of any consequence,
which is basically a draw,
uh,
but in which,
the Brit,
British navy forces the Germans back,
uh,
this is,
you know,
in the next war will force the Germans
back into port of battle up here.
So the last thing they do that the,
that the British,
uh,
think that they can do is lose control.
The seas and all these big German ships
in the kind of aggressive way that there
are not graded by this,
you know,
uh,
Nicholas or via,
the Kaiser Wilhelm,
the second,
you know,
banging bottles of,
uh,
of,
German champagne over
the ships and giving it,
you know,
more,
uh,
heated speeches about Germany's
destiny in place in the world,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And so what happens is that
basically the British government,
uh,
which is to say,
you know,
for a long time it said,
well,
we're not gonna.
We don't need to make an
alliance with anyone else,
uh,
with anyone at all.
Uh,
now,
um,
as tension,
economic tension followed by political
enabled tension of between Germany and,
uh,
and Britain,
increased,
they increased,
they begin looking to across
the channel to z French.
Um,
and,
um,
I said,
I said earlier that in,
in the eighties and nineties,
and the full Shota incident is in what,
1890,
1898 or 99.
I can't remember.
It doesn't matter if you ask people in
Paris or Leon or some big city or Boldo,
uh,
it were,
the next war was going to be,
they would say it's against the British.
And let me give you an example of that.
Uh,
there were lots of people expected wars.
You know,
there are these folks that are writing
future war novels and it's just that,
you know,
as you and val and all of that,
and there were these sort of science,
uh,
inspired novels and writing that
reflected Eq electricity and,
and it's our space wars kind of stuff.
But there were also future war novels.
And,
um,
one of the more ridiculous ones,
the author of,
of,
of which escapes me,
uh,
was a novel published that had
some success in England in,
in the 1890s.
And it involves a future war against whom,
not the Germans,
but against the French.
And the novel goes something like this.
I mean,
would never want to read such a thing.
Uh,
is that the people in,
uh,
you know,
Dover down here,
the white cliffs of Dover,
one day they wake up on
Sunday morning and my God,
the,
the French have arrived,
uh,
and in there a sneaky ways they have
been digging a tunnel under the English
Channel.
Now Napoleon wanted to dig a
tunnel under the English Channel.
We now have a tunnel under
the English Channel was,
and there again about four to
five weeks ago or six weeks ago.
Um,
ray rapidly,
the,
you know,
the fast train that finally
after all these years,
the British finally did their part and
now at the train actually runs fairly
fast after rice,
a Dover instead of just,
you know,
slinking along in the mud
until it gets to London.
But,
uh,
so these folks go out to have their,
you know,
their,
uh,
greasy eggs and chips and all this kind
of stuff and on a Sunday morning and
they suddenly see z French
are there and they are armed.
And you know,
they have been,
they have snuck through this tunnel
that's been being built underneath and
they're sneaky ways and then
they pop up with their guns.
And the thing that's a ludicrous,
I mean talk about national
stereotypes is that in this novel,
the soldiers,
at least the avant garde,
the first people arriving are
dressed as French waiters,
uh,
and under their large,
you know,
dirty napkins.
Again,
this is the British image
of the French as large are,
are sneaky weapons that they have been,
you know,
they have been,
uh,
a building and then the hiding.
And of course they rush out,
they seized over,
and then the,
uh,
the British people,
you know,
rally and of course a,
they call out the constables and they
drive them back into the tunnel and plug
up the tunnel.
And that's the end of that.
Of course,
it's a call for,
you know,
for more military preparation,
etc.
You know,
there's another similar novel,
uh,
written in a,
you know,
about 1904 and 1805.
And it's simply,
it doesn't involve people in
Dover involves people up in,
you know,
Whitby Scarborough and the northeastern
coast where the wind is always
horizontal and the rain is pounding on
you from every conceivable direction and
they wake up and what they see are these
huge dreadnought battleships lobbing
enormous shells and destroying
British homes in British people,
uh,
with big guns.
And the point of the novel outside of,
you know,
putting people to sleep,
uh,
was to get,
to encourage yet more military
preparations to fight a war,
not against the French anymore,
but against the Germans
and events in 1905,
the first Moroccan crisis,
which you can read about
in chip star wines,
book followed inevitably in 1911
by the second to Moroccan crisis.
What this has to do with
German Saber rattling in,
uh,
in Morocco,
I into untold shaves.
Tangiers specifically in the
second case in which the czar,
those are the Kaiser himself,
uh,
shows up.
And what this does is it convinces the,
the,
the British that maybe,
you know,
allying with the French isn't
such a dumb idea after all.
And so they begin to have informal
military talks that become formal military
talks that become an entente,
same word in English.
And understanding that's a formal
understanding where they're sitting down
saying the obvious things.
You,
the British navy,
we'll take care of the English Channel.
You'll take care of the North Sea.
Uh,
we,
the French navy in tunnel,
uh,
down here,
we will be responsible for the defense of,
uh,
of the Mediterranean.
And this is of course,
more this isn't because of
the influence of Germany,
uh,
in,
in Turkey.
And Turkey will find
the come in as you know,
in the war on the German side,
thus Gallipoli's where the British
officers send all the Australians and New
Zealanders to,
to die this certain death up a heel
that couldn't possibly be conquered.
Ah,
ah,
this what they sent in
British soldiers to,
they sent everybody.
Uh,
but anyway,
so it's more,
you know,
there is a reason also because Austria,
Hungary then did have a port.
Uh,
uh,
so,
this is no mere gesture toward the French,
but this explains hot.
Was that these,
these,
uh,
these two also fairly unlikely powers,
come together more ever.
Moreover,
remember what I've come
back to two or three times.
Uh,
the birth rate.
you know,
the French,
uh,
realize that the,
that you know,
they're there if the ward,
if it's more than just a short encounter
and Lord knows who had become VAD,
uh,
more about this during World War One,
that the,
their birth rate is,
is so minuscule compared to the rest of
Europe that you better have allies if
you're going to be fighting the Germans,
you better have allies.
And everybody knew what
the birth rates were.
Here,
just some example,
this is live birth per
a thousand inhabitants,
1908,
1913.
So key period,
um,
France,
19.5,
England 24.9.
Okay.
Germany,
29.5.
Okay.
European,
Russia,
45.6 in Italy,
32.4.
So military planners know this stuff.
They know that exactly.
And that means it's all that more
important for the French if they're
contemplating this war
to take that space back,
to count on all of these people.
But it will take these people,
as I said,
two weeks to mobilize.
And that's why the declaration,
the mobile,
the act of mobilization,
the decree of the czar is
tantamount to an act of war.
Because what this does is this is
leaping ahead and I'll come back to it,
but it's important enough that it's
worth coming back to what this tells the
Germans.
They have two weeks in
order to defeat France.
They're sure they can do it and then
you better stop because this big bear,
it's going to have mobilized all of these
people in Central Asia and other parts
and they're going to be lumbering
towards you so you better stop him in two
weeks.
How are you going to do that?
French have big forts all along here,
here and there and everywhere.
The way your and you know they're going
to want move immediately into Alsace.
Sohan more about this again later.
So the way to do it and
not for the last time,
they are willing to
violate Belgian neutrality,
induction neutrality.
So that disappears from the
plan to Schlieffen plan,
which I'll come back to.
A Nike written in 1905 is predicated on
the fact that the French are going to
invade SSRN and so you just
sweep into a neutral country,
Belgium since 19 neutral since
1831 now what does that do?
That guarantees that
without any question at all
guarantees that the
British will go to war.
Why for the British it seems bad enough
to have the French across the channel,
but what did you have the
Germans in Belgium in Austan,
which this is a short
hop across the channel
and really is the shortest way or one
of the two shortest ways to get across.
So that's impossible.
You can't have that.
So you're going to go to war.
Now,
was that a risk that your,
why was that a risk that
Germans were willing to take?
Because the English,
the British do not have a conscript army.
They have a tiny army,
it's called an expeditionary force
and we'll take them a long time,
months and maybe longer to raise the kind
of army that could make any difference
in the long run here in
France and in Belgium.
So these deck,
these cards is house of cards,
is there.
These entangling alliances are there.
And so that's basically what happens in,
in,
you know,
in 1914 is when I remember we're going
to Sarajevo before it was destroyed in
the nineties.
And I remember putting my seat word,
the 16 year old gunner,
uh,
principally,
put his feet as he and when the archduke
Franz Ferdinand driver had the data.
Do you have backing up after having missed
a turn after they tried to kill them
once and then prince of suddenly finds
himself with the arch bishop or the
Archbishop,
the archduke and his wife there
and he blows them away right there.
This leads to the blank check and it,
it's going to what,
and you can read about this.
You already know it from
high school history.
It brings,
it brings Europe into this,
uh,
this dreadful war.
Now,
some more things,
uh,
some more things.
Um,
first,
uh,
let me just give you,
do I have time for that?
Yeah.
Let,
let me give you an example of,
of how the stakes get,
uh,
the tension gets heated up.
Now again,
like revolutions,
wars don't necessarily break out of,
uh,
according to the hydraulic model where
things are awful in 1910 and 1911,
that's even more tans 1912,
oh my God.
1913,
1914.
It's got to come.
It doesn't work like that.
Um,
you know,
[inaudible] you have the
Balkan wars going on,
uh,
a dominant,
the Balkans appropriately enough,
you know,
and,
uh,
a couple of years before
World War One and all of that.
But there are these,
these moments like 1905,
the first Moroccan affair in 1911,
the second Moroccan affair,
uh,
that raise the tensions between these
countries and make it possible for the
kid,
for the popular press and sort of the
culture of war to target the enemy that
you know,
the enemy for the future war.
And in this incident,
uh,
[inaudible],
is at least interesting enough to
Ah,
no,
in German,
in France,
uh,
to discuss because it,
you know,
it leads to this,
this increase in tension.
And this is his 1913 now el sauce.
Um,
uh,
LCFF and parts of Lauren
are annexed in 1871,
but the German high co,
the German,
uh,
government doesn't
really trust El Stations.
In fact,
they don't have the same statute
within the empire as the other parts of
Germany,
such as Bavaria,
Vertin Berg or Hanover that they have are
Pomerania or Brandenburg or any of the
other states.
Um,
they,
they are,
uh,
they are part of the,
of the empire,
but they don't have all the rights as a
matter of fact that the representatives
in the right stock from Alsace and
Lauryn cannot vote on certain key,
you know,
foreign policy matters and,
and,
and all of that.
So there's a lot of tension there.
But again,
showing the,
the,
the sort of people can
have multiple identities,
you know,
to be sure many people
left El Sauce and uh,
and,
and the hen and move
to Paris and move to a,
uh,
move to bell fark and all sorts of Naafi
and all sorts of places after 1871,
because they didn't want to be German.
But El Sauce,
it is basically an end.
Lorenn is basically
German speaking in 1913,
uh,
the total,
just to give you an example,
uh,
of the number of communes in,
um,
uh,
administrative units in 1913,
385 spoke French refreshes
the majority language in 385,
1000,
225 our German speaking and 86,
uh,
no one has a majority.
So in other words,
77% of the communes in,
in El Sauce and,
and the parts of Lauren that were annexed
our German speaking yet many people
and not all,
but many people.
And we don't know how many,
uh,
consider themselves French
even though they spoke German.
Well,
why not?
There are lots of people
who had multiple identities,
we've talked about her boss to field
that their fracture or Gospel or Provence
style or or Flemish,
et cetera,
et cetera.
So,
um,
you've got this sort of,
that situation.
But Alsace is terribly
important because what,
when you go up to the
border between Alsace,
a old franchise off in Germany,
Alsace,
you've got this,
this cracks are these,
uh,
what'd he say?
Catholic.
Anyway,
it is in English.
You have these,
you know,
these mountains,
these,
these summit's really,
and you've got this road,
a military road all along the top.
Uh,
and so it's an important frontier point.
And so for the point of view of
the German military in particular,
they don't trust the trustee.
All stations,
even though they speak German,
they speak the same German that is spoke,
uh,
spoken across the,
across the Rhine River,
uh,
in,
in Fribourg,
uh,
for example.
And what this incident takes place in
1913 does is it confirms the image of
German aggressiveness,
uh,
and,
um,
it,
there's a chance that
could have brought war.
I mean,
it doesn't,
but there are other reasons too.
Why,
why Berlin does not trust,
uh,
Alsatians why?
One reason is that,
remember,
Bismarck is totally anti Catholic.
You know,
any,
he wages this war on the Catholics
called the couture comp for the,
or the,
uh,
the,
the cultural war against the Catholics.
And within the German empire,
you've got Catholics in the Rhineland,
you've got Catholics dominant in,
in Bavaria,
uh,
and you've got Catholics were in El Sauce,
and this is part of the problem too.
So you've got to,
uh,
this,
these tensions between,
uh,
between German officers and,
and,
and Alsatian,
uh,
citizens.
Uh,
and finally,
1911,
Alsace,
Lorraine is recognized as,
as a,
as a federal state,
but they still have to abstain on issues
of war treaties and constitutional
amendments.
So you've got this little
town called Xavi on,
which is very pretty place eight,
8,000 people with a
canal running through it.
Uh,
you've got your basic German officers
where they're dueling scars and lots of
tension,
uh,
between,
civilians and soldiers.
Um,
and the tension was made
worse when a German officer,
uh,
and,
indeed speaking to some Alsatian
soldiers who were there,
they tried to being soldiers
from other parts of,
of,
of the empire,
to be soldiers in there the
way that you would never find,
uh,
you know,
Castilian or you'll never
find a cat that last soldiers,
uh,
you know,
guarding,
uh,
Barcelona,
you'd find Castilian soldiers.
Uh,
he,
he refers to all El
stations in extraordinarily,
uh,
scatological and pejorative term,
a in German slang.
And people don't like that.
There's a lot of tension
and that word spreads.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
an officer says,
you know,
I don't care if you kill these bastards.
You know,
what a good thing that would be,
or something like that.
And so word spreads.
And it turned out there was a,
you know,
a junior officer who had
had the very bad idea of,
uh,
of sleeping with a 14 year old,
Alsatian woman.
And so some of the l station,
uh,
guys get a little drunk and then they
pull them out of the room and beat the
hell out of him.
Uh,
and so things get get,
uh,
you know,
which probably a good idea,
but I mean,
they shouldn't have done that,
but it,
it,
uh,
it goes from there.
It going from there,
and then the German high command and
the newspapers get involved in this,
and they make it seem like there'd been
insults to the German flag to the German
emperor by these people who cannot be
trusted because they are who they are,
et cetera.
And of course,
the French says,
say,
well,
these are real French people who are
being attacked and indeed molested in one
case,
uh,
you know,
child rape,
uh,
essentially,
at least legally,
uh,
by these horrible huns and everything,
it just,
right.
The tension level goes out.
Now they don't go to war but,
but it confirms these kinds of
stereotypes that you would see by the way,
in the first year of the
war two where the images of,
you know,
the Rudel,
uh,
German and there were atrocities.
There were,
there were atrocities committed by
Germans more than were committed by other
people on the western front.
That's without question.
And all these rumors,
you know,
that kind of confirm this,
this image that is in many ways faults,
but there was enough of a grain of truth
in it that goes back to this incident.
So this minor incident,
you know,
essentially a shouting match and a fight
in a small town in El sauce has huge
implications.
And what it does is it helps confirm
not only the image of the other,
but it confirms,
you know,
these milk,
these military plans,
uh,
that from the franchise can be
very important for the home front,
particularly that you
better when the war starts,
get your self into Alsace and
Lauryn and take Alsace Lauren back.
You know,
some of them think,
well,
we can't really be,
are they not going to
really go through Belgium?
Are they,
they think that maybe they're
going to be fighting them here.
Of course,
that all will happen,
uh,
a later.
But,
um,
so in 1914,
there really aren't any
surprises the way it,
and the people who tried to stop the war,
like Sir Edward Gray,
who sends that said the lights
are going out all over Europe.
They will not be lit
against in our lifetime.
Man,
did he ever have that right?
You know,
absolutely.
Right.
Because the war,
1914 to 1944 is basically
one continuous poisonous war,
a new,
terrible 30 years' war.
Uh,
but once this had all been set up,
there wasn't much could happen.
I mean,
the stop it and the way the war,
the way the military planning
it goes is it helps explain,
and I will explain next Monday how it
was that this war that was supposed to be
over before the leaves
fall over before Christmas,
home,
before Christmas,
et Cetera,
and knock Berlin and knock puppies.
Uh,
uh,
Auburn.
You know,
it goes on for years and years and carries
away an entire generation of people,
of young men,
um,
an entire generation.
Uh,
it's built in to the planning
and we will see how that happens.
It's a terribly important,
so a story.
And then certainly there is
no event in the 20th century,
uh,
in which there were so
much been written on this,
on how the war started.
I remember my uncle,
my great uncle who fought in,
you know,
for American,
he was an American and
he fought in the 1917,
1918 and all that I
remember and I just didn't,
I was a little teeny guy when he,
when he died,
but you know,
they gave me,
they had all the book of the documents
showing that the Germans started at all
with the Germans didn't start at all.
And that would have a huge impact on what
happens in Germany in 20s and 30s and
thus be very important.
But,
but that's why this is
an important subject.
And just in conclusion,
what else can we say
when obviously it's not,
it's not only these diplomatic factors
and not only this military planning that
brings about this war,
there's more to it than that.
And Charles alluded to,
uh,
a very,
very effectively,
very cleverly,
uh,
to some of the other
factors the other day.
And I,
I barely need to repeat them,
but that,
uh,
the imperial rivalry helps create
this culture of popular imperialism,
which feeds in to this culture of popular,
aggressive nationalism
that in which the other,
uh,
whether it be an indigenous person
who dare stand up for his or her,
you know,
rights in,
in,
uh,
Malia or somewhere like that.
Uh,
it,
the next stage is
identifying if the other,
the dangerous other as being ones,
uh,
enemy,
traditional enemy in some,
in the case of Germany and,
and,
uh,
and France,
on,
on the continent.
And we call this jingoism,
uh,
from a,
from a poem that was in a,
in a British newspaper.
I think that's where it started
by Jingo we'll get them,
et cetera,
et cetera.
By Jingo,
we get them.
And jingoism basically means
aggressive nationalism.
And it's this expectation,
uh,
that war will come.
Uh,
which not only,
you know,
the military,
uh,
Joseph said to one of the
high commanded in France,
he said,
he anticipate every day
he dreamt of the next war.
And what it would be like
that it would be wonderful,
thrilling,
and the whole light in social and PR,
the social Darwinist idea that you know,
that you've got the
survival of the fittest,
but you know,
if you're going to show
you are the fittest,
what a better way to do it.
Then instead of just dueling with some,
you know,
some guy in your own national team,
getting in dueling scar on some general
that you core with over a woman in a,
in a,
in a tavern sometime now
you're going to show that you,
you feel a nationality.
The British,
the French,
the Germans,
the Russians,
uh,
you name it,
that you're the best and
you're going to show them,
uh,
and you're going to show
them on the battlefield.
And so the point of view of the French,
I mean,
when,
when it has to keep in mind
is the French war invaded.
You know,
the French did not invade Germany.
The Germans invaded France say too.
Wow.
But,
uh,
the,
but nonetheless,
it was this expectation
of war and it wait,
fits into,
you know,
into these equivalent and boy's life
magazines and popular novels about the
future war painting,
the map of the world,
the color of your particular country,
red in the case of of Britain,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
All of this comes together and,
and,
and it helps us try to explain this,
this great enthusiasm,
at least in the big
cities at told Bahnhof in,
in Berlin or at the Gal de last in Paris,
uh,
for this war.
Now,
whether people in other parts of France
and Germany and other places were
enthusiastic about the war,
you know,
it's a very moot question.
That's been not been a hotly
debated in many places.
Obviously they had better things
to do there to get the harvest in,
which would be one problem,
uh,
on the home front and every place
cause the war starts in the,
in,
in the summer.
But,
but the expectation of war
and the culture of war,
uh,
closely tied to,
to,
uh,
the culture of,
of nationalism,
aggressive nationalism tied to imperialism
and economic rivalry and everything
else helps explain how
this war came about.
Uh,
and the,
the idea of how people accepted the
wars more complicated depending on it,
dependent on,
you know,
where the army is,
war and,
and all of this.
And that's a remarkable story.
And instead that,
that all turned in the
second lecture next week,
uh,
the home front,
the first lecture next week will be how
we ended up with this trench warfare
that has been so dominant in the visual
images of the war in the museums about
the war.
Uh,
and in that great
literature about the war,
some which you'll be reading
when you read Bob Loose,
are they.